and it's the truth that there is no
other religion that makes an article if
to believe in love Jesus is one of the
mightiest messengers of God but they say
now they say no no you don't love him
because you don't accept him as the only
begotten Son of God well that's John
3:16 it's a 5 / okc point number 1 as we
discussed the son of god the concept of
son of god in the bible the bible has a
language it has a language with it
refuse to anyone and everyone as son of
god it refers to adam ascent of god
david a son of god are the prophets a
son of god it says sons and daughters of
god it even says in book of romans
chapter 8 verse 14 that anyone who
believes in god follows god is the son
of god it's it's a metaphor so
everyone's a son of god based on that so
as but if you look at the original greek
hebrew word which the jews used to
believe in they would translate the word
son of god and they would understand it
as servant of god
so as muslims we do believe that jesus
is son of servant of god and jesus and
every other prophet is servant of god
including me you and everyone else so we
are all servants of god so truly from
the Christian perspective from the
biblical scripture is scriptural
perspective Muslims do believe in Jesus
the way he should be believed in that is
the servant of God